I'm joined today by Laci green who is a
sex educator youtuber author of sex +
learning loving and enjoying your body
so much to talk about Laci up maybe a
good place to start is you were raised
Mormon and no longer are talked about
that a little bit because we've talked
to former Mormons who have had sort of
different paths out of Mormonism like
what was your path like um well when I
was about 12 years old I don't know how
much she know about Mormonism but pretty
early on they split you up by gender yes
and I would say that that was around the
time that I started realizing that there
were things about the church that made
me feel uncomfortable mostly coming back
to the gender stuff I think that in the
Mormon religion there's a really strong
adherence to gender roles and that was
really a lien ating to me as a kid cuz
you know I was I was kind of like a
tomboy I did not like all this like
crafty let's talk about babysitting and
you know it was just like a weird it
just struck me as weird as a kid and I
think that's kind of what started my
exit out once I realized that there was
a lot of misogyny in how the church how
at least you know the church that I was
a part of conducted itself
yeah and correct me if I'm wrong but
like one of the main pillars of
Mormonism is that and again my you'll
correct me I'm sure I believe that there
is it 12 apostles who can only ever be
men right yeah and the leaders can only
be men and you know when you're a kid
when you're you go through puberty as a
girl they tell you that your spiritual
role on earth is to have babies like
that is what you do that it's the most
divine capacity that you have and I just
think that's really sexist you know like
I'll just be really frank about it
telling telling young girls but their
greatest spiritual value lies in their
ability to have babies is a really
messed up thing to tell girls of course
it's great if you want to have babies
and it's beautiful and it is powerful
but that's not all that girls are you
know that's where
it started to trip me up a little bit so
did you first express these hesitations
to your family did they were they taken
aback by your eventual leaving yes I
fought with my parents constantly as a
teenager you know probably starting
around thirteen or fourteen and told
them how I felt about it and told them
that I think it's sexist and told them
that I think you know a lot of this
stuff is it doesn't make any sense there
is a lot of weird stuff about sex like
masturbation is strictly off-limits and
I would have to go in to go to the
temple in the church you have to go talk
to one of your church leaders a guy
privately and he like asked me all these
questions about if I masturbate and like
how I touch myself and there's all this
weird yeah weird weird it's like that
shouldn't be this shouldn't be like a
regular process in the church why why is
it seen as normal for young teenagers to
go talk about their sexuality with these
weird old dudes I don't know it's just
rubs me the wrong way and I told my
parents and they got very defensive
about it but you know we're on better
terms now yeah well we're going to ask
about that like is is leave you know
leaving Scientology has a very specific
meaning where is like unless you're in
the most Orthodox Hasidic Jewish
communities leaving Judaism is almost
like a non it just doesn't mean I need
there's no reason I think whatsoever
that it'll have any impact on your
relationship with your family where does
leaving Mormonism sort of rank on that
spectrum can you still maintain the same
relationships or almost the same with
your family I think it depends on the
family with mine absolutely I'm very
close to my family you know we we have
very very close relationships and
they're healthy relationships for the
most part so I think you know it would
be it's possible if my parents were not
that cool that we would be estranged
because of that I dunno Mormon kids ex
Mormons who have been estranged but
there's no like official guidance where
you need to disown not that I know of
anyway you need you to send someone for
leaving the church so what I find super
interesting about
was that as you just described your
initial sort of hesitations concerns
about Mormonism were heavily related to
gender and what you perceive to be and I
would agree with you are sexist and
misogynistic sort of policies or or
ideas and in your earlier work on
YouTube and and on other platforms you
had a very sort of particular feminist
perspective and over time I think it
might be fair to say that you have had a
sort of political awakening or maybe we
would call it a realignment of sorts is
that fair to say I can see why it looks
that way in the public but I would say
that I feel all the same things I've
always felt I just say more interesting
so what give me an example of that
because so for people who maybe aren't
familiar with you as as much of my
research shows which you're free of
course to dispute you have maybe moved a
little more away from the feminist side
and maybe are finding more value in some
of the anti SJW anti-feminist milieu of
the Internet is that fair I don't think
that's accurate good I'm glad we can
talk about that I do not agree in any
capacity with anti-feminists okay and I
don't agree in any capacity on anything
substantive with the anti sjw crowd
okay good side that said here's where I
think we're getting to the key part
that's it yes
I I think that there are plenty of smart
people in that crowd I think that their
arguments are worth addressing and have
more nuanced than sometimes people give
them credit for good and where I do
agree with them this is probably the
only thing we agree on and why I become
really good friends with a lot of people
that move in that sphere is that I also
agree that the way that social justice
stuff is carried out sometimes is really
toxic and bad oh yeah okay so you and I
are completely on the same page as far
as that goes that okay cool yeah I mean
when I like really sit down and I talk
to people about this stuff people who
have been angry
about things they've seen about me
online or whatever usually we agree it's
like I didn't change my mind I'm not
like less of a feminist I don't think
the anti feminists have like good points
or something I haven't changed my mind I
feel just as strongly as I always have
however I think that there are some
crazy people on the left like there are
some very Wow some really wild stuff out
there and when you say that lacy are
there particular is it is it just the
people and the way they couch their
argument or are there actually specific
claims or arguments being made on the
left that you hear and you say I just
simply don't agree with that I'm sure
there are arguments being made that I
don't agree with I I so I guess one of
the main ones is like some of the some
of the criticisms that are made about
the way that identity politics are used
the way that they're employed I think
there are pros and cons to identity
politics obviously the entire feminist
movement is about women's identity you
know female identity so I don't think
that identity politics are bad will sail
but I do think some of this like more
inflammatory clickbait be weird stuff
that people do with identity politics is
really causing a lot of harm and
alienation of people who could be allies
to these causes who otherwise agree but
are being told oh you're like this
you're white male you know straight
white men you're trash you're garbage
things like that it's just like why do
you have to do that I don't understand
how prevalent is that like I I basically
I'm on board with what you're saying
with the exception that I can probably
count on only one hand and I'd probably
have fingers left over for messaging
that is straight up like straight white
men or garbage like I'm just not seeing
that and that my feeling from the
research I've done is that it's vastly
overblown that that exists how serious
of initiative you think that perspective
is on the left okay I used to feel the
same way that you did until I really
started waiting in talking to people
about this kind of stuff in a more
holistic capacity I guess and I do think
it's a problem I do see a lot of it
online
I don't think that that is like the most
pressing issue I think it's silly that
people are so defensive about what some
random egghead on Twitter said you know
but I also think that the discourse that
kind of discourse is becoming it has
become more commonly accepted it's
become a way to signal you're woken asau
the people and to show other people how
progressive you are you know the virtual
virtual signalling stuff that people
talk about I think that's a real thing
and I am also annoyed by it
I think it's obnoxious and unnecessary
and for me it makes it hard to connect
with people on the ground when about you
know feminism sexism whatever when their
first exposure to this stuff is from you
know some really inflammatory comments
online and obviously that's I agree with
you it's not like widespread it's not
like a defining thing within progressive
movement but I think that it has become
acceptable to acceptable and I do think
that that kind of stuff has become too
common online especially because you
identified that there are some people on
the right that are very very smart
people and I'd love to not that I don't
agree with that but I'd love to get that
list from you do you get a sense that
the alt-right recognizes that often
while critiquing identity politics they
are effectively an identity movement do
you do you feel like they understand
that or do you think that definitely
missing from from their understanding of
what's going on I don't I don't think
they understand that they're doing the
exact same thing that they are not at
other people for doing that's the
hilarity of the alt-right the white
identity stuff it's like you know you
guys are identity politicians as well
like you're out here you you're mad
about feminism you're mad about black
lives matter and yet you're doing like
this weird white lives whatever you know
it's just it's all it's all the same
thing of course the white life stuff is
different in a very critical sense
because they're not marginalized you
know these are people who don't have
real systemic barriers yeah I spoke
about that I don't know if you've been
following this him to hash tag thing I
spoke about it yesterday on the pro
and you know I find that what's missing
from the conversation about if you can
have a me-too movement then you can have
a hem to movement about men who are
falsely accused of sexual assault or if
there's an LGBT Student Union then why
is it not okay to have a straight
student unit and I feel like what's
missing from the discourse is the
historical understanding of why these
groups have sort of surfaced in the
first place and whether they've served
the stout of good faith or in bad faith
I don't know how to have that
conversation successfully with people on
the right do you know how that you can
broach that issue I have had that
conversation but I think that for some
people they don't care about the context
because they don't really fully
understand the context I think that's
really what it comes down to you like a
lot of people are removed from the
history of these issues and you know why
as you said why things are the way they
are now and why be the context is
everything here I don't know how to
impress upon people the importance of
context either acknowledge that that is
a really important part of the
conversation or you leave a huge aspect
of the conversation out which is how we
got here in the first place
I find that frustrating as well I wanted
to touch base with you about the sort of
relative importance of different issues
today and there's a big debate right now
not about the substance there there is a
debate about the substance of many of
these issues like gender pronouns for
example or the me2 versus the hymn to
movement or whatever but then there's
also a conversation about what issues
should actually be prioritized in 2018
so is there an issue right now that you
think is getting way more attention than
it actually deserves but then also on
the other hand are there issues right
now that should be getting much more
discussion that aren't really being
talked about mmm that's a good question
I think there's probably too much focus
on feminist media on the media like on
representative media and stuff which I
do think is important and I do think
that it's important to you need
do you sort of critical thinking about
the media that we consume and the types
of messages that are in it okay I do you
think that's important but I think it is
disproportionately paid attention to and
people fight about it way like they
would invest a lot of time and energy
into fighting about that particular
issue and to make sure I understand what
is you do mean whether particular
identities are represented in the news
that but also you know is this new
Netflix show properly feminist oh god
you know was this comment that
such-and-such celebrity made problematic
you know just like things that I would
that you have to ask yourself okay what
are we gonna get out of this on a
societal scale by investing a huge
amount of time and resources into this
one issue right and I don't think that
it's proportionate I don't think that's
a good the most pressing issue of our
time I do think it's important like I
said I don't want people to like of
course people are gonna take me out of
context either way but yeah I do think
it's really important and I do think
that there is tremendous value in those
conversations but I also think that
there are there are very serious issues
at stake right now in our country and
with regard to women particularly we are
having reproductive rights completely
roll back I mean it is jarring to me
what's going on and what's been going on
for a long time but now here we are with
all his cabinet stuff and we're in a
really really vulnerable and precarious
position right now with regard to
reproductive rights
sex ed birth control just everything
relating to sexual health and freedom
and I mean there has been stuff because
there has been stuff online because of
the cabinet stuff but before that I just
don't really feel like anyone really
talks about abortion or talks about how
these things are happening it's almost
like it's not a sexy enough issue I
think that when a comes down to is that
when it's about legislation that's being
debated it has to reach a much higher
threshold of salaciousness before it
will enter the dialog then for example
someone like Jordan Peterson saying
I'm being forced to or will be punished
for using this or that gender pronoun
and I think that that's the issue in
general that you're kind of describing
which is that the media coverage that
develops around personalities on these
issues seems to be much more powerful
than the actual legislation around those
issues which could affect way more
people directly absolutely you said it
perfectly well that's exactly how I feel
and I think that something that
frustrates me is that there's not enough
recalibration there is within
professional activists or circles but
just you know the mainstream sort of
feminist movement people who are talking
about this stuff online as a hobby or
interests I think they don't pay enough
attention attention to the things that
really matter and the things that are
really gonna have the most direct effect
on people's lives you know another
example is the health care to be it's
happening in the u.s. if people
literally can't afford to survive then
what good is defending the perfectly
constructed feminists narrative in a
movie you know like I just priorities
that's how I feel about it we've been
speaking with Laci green who is a sex
educator youtuber also author of sex
Plus learning loving and enjoying your
body Laci really great to talk to you
today you do David thanks for having me